die kanalratten was jetzt nicht
willkommen im neuen mini auf einen kanal
und zwei spielen wir heute dort wave da
ist so ein punkt und ein welt kompakt
ist das laub ich habe das spiel noch
nicht gespielt mir wurde vorgeschlagen
von euch in den kommentaren weil ich
dabei gesagt unter solchen spielen könnt
ihr mir in die kommentare spiele
schreiben die ich auch mal spielen soll
und da geht es einmal tutorial ist wenn
man es folgen
damit ich erst mal weiß dass sie
überhaupt abgeht okay ich kann wenn ich
nichts drücke bei dem boden schleudern
wenn ich jetzt gedrückt halte bin ich
oben wenn ich da nur elise widerwillig
unten
was muss denn gebäuden um ein fucking
what was das hat sich gedreht das war
umbringt und versucht das tier für eine
scheiße herzlich das volk wohl gerade
oder ich weiß nicht das ist so ganz
grelles wetter draußen deswegen ist die
beleuchtung richtig cool also kommen wie
man das jetzt noch mal das kann man
nicht so also jetzt
ich muss doch hier einfach mal wieso
dreht sich das spiel jetzt nicht das
tutorial sondern wir machen jetzt mal
random was ist das
jetzt gleicht dieser wiki [ __ ] gleich
dreht sich die scheußliche bestimmt
wieder und ich das für ein verbrechen
das selbst in not war das kann doch
nicht sein
doch was ist das denn wo geht es geht
noch aber wenn es jetzt gleich was
passiert wenn man die scheiße auf drogen
spielen wenn sich das dann auf einmal
irgendwie so verrät also ich meine art
da kommt man nicht lang was ist denn ok
spiele ich auf hart das kann ich spiele
ich jetzt aufhörst ich war schon die
ganze lokal oder als auch das normale
fan das sich die ganze zeit behindert
dreht alles okay ich habe kurz überlegt
ob ich rotation mache habe ich bleib
doch mal noch mal kurz beim rendern
machen jetzt mal random fahrt sondern
versuchen wir
mal ob es rotiert sich dann einfach mehr
oder fakt ist dass immer knapp fucking
fucks ist so unfassbar wie lange meine
harisch wieder sind komplex dass man die
gehen fasst bis zu meiner nase also die
gehen bis zu 1 anders aber so rüber
drüber und bleibe ich auch wieso erzähle
ich euch dass überhaupt ein solches am
hafen im bug that shit
ich werde jetzt einfach wie ein gott oh
mein gott das ist doch nicht es ist
natürlich nicht mein gott notdienst ja
direkt zwei straßen weiter genau
nee ich glaube es kann aber geplatzt
aufgelegt oh mein gott warum denn ich
hab das studium das ist somit dass
abgefragt ist das spiel was ich in
letzter zeit gespielt hat er natürlich
so dass wie johnny cash oder so hat mich
auch mega abgefragt um mein gott wie so
dreht sich dass man auf einmal aber das
sind halt zuspiele wissen oder kann das
kann man cool zusammenschneiden
da muss man sich auch nicht und und hier
und da sondern weil wir nicht sogar
spielen würde was total einfach wäre mit
viel story und soll er dann könnte ich
da gar nicht so viel schneit und schneit
macht mir halt zurzeit einfach wie
fucking facto fakt dreht sich das denn
weil sie schneiden macht mit der zeit
als echt schon mega viel spaß bei ihnen
welche videos ich denke das merkt man
dass ich jetzt einfach mein mikrofon
wieder kommen was ist dass ich hab das
letzte mal hier schon ein bisschen
kaputt gemacht alle blicke auf uns denn
keiner
kanada ist und bleibt
das ist doch nicht wahr sein bestes zehn
sekunden muss es doch besser schaffen
als hier irgendwie mal zehn sekunden
drin zu überleben
ich meine das spiel an sich würde ich
locker hinkriegen aber es dreht sich
halt die dabei tuna gefragt weil das ich
hab ich grad kopfschmerzen von dem spiel
alter [ __ ] super mega weh weil ich habe
eine frage ich hatte gerade ganz
plötzlich sondern schwächen im kopf
irgendwie soll ich dann eine
kopfschmerztablette nehmen oder einfach
abwarten
alles gut gerade ja okay okay okay ich
hatte echt einfach so ein stechen im
hinterkopf
ich weiß nicht dass du das hatte ich
schon zweimal das hatte ich schon mal
das video es glaube ich in die ader
geplatzt oder irgendwo das war bei
freestyle herumgeschrien und dann hatte
ich irgendwie hier hinten auch so ein
stechen und dann zwei neue high score
fig tabletten alter ich mache noch 9
so schwer kann das doch nicht sein wenn
ich jetzt hier schon eben gerade einfach
hier
oh mein gott einfach hier eben schnell
und aktiv und spuckt die dings und hier
und blau und kacke ins maul werfen dann
bin ich hier natürlich direkt auf der
alter das ist nicht wahr was ist denn
mit meinem kopf hier
das war gerade ganz plötzlich auf einmal
kommt zum blöde stechen hier da circa
und jetzt jetzt tut alles weh irgendwie
als wenn man so was nicht gerade als
wenn man wenig geschlafen hat oder so
was ist denn das für ein spiel das nicht
könnt ihr euch noch an dieses video
erinnern an diesem sperma simulator wo
ich dann so ein manager einer das blatt
vor den opfern um irgendwie von oh mein
gott das sieht richtig highscore
verdächtig aus fakt der chip wie soll
ich denn da klar kommen oh mein gott oh
gott oh gott das ist der allerletzte an
iwate freundin man ist froh dass er mir
vorhin schon gesagt das letzte mal
rotation auf hart machen
das ist doch nicht wahr was ist das denn
für eine abgefuckte scheiße hier die
durch das maribor mein gott nächste
runde geht rückwärts oder wie jetzt nee
das ist doch nicht wahr das ist doch
einfach nur nicht schön das ist doch
einfach nur für deinen kopf spielt es
bitte nicht ich gehe ich lasse jetzt
sein mir gehts echt bissel blöd
kopf trat mega wie ich weiß nicht woher
das kommt ja wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen weil ich an solchen videos immer
mega lange sitze was ich gehe zum
friseur
ich gehe jetzt zum friseur das ist mir
eindeutig zu lang wenn ihr irgendwelche
spieler kennt die ich eventuell auch mal
spielen soll schreibt in die kommentare
wir sehen uns mal in echt auf dem video
days da bin ich nämlich donnerstag
freitag samstag sonntag in berlin